so surprised at the choice you mentioned  the modern chess as well I noticed the  Young Generation they do prefer to  defend actively I mean the fact that  he's even hesitating on Queen E3 check  right now  um really shows that he's unsure about  this end game but  I think needs must hear 23 otherwise  you're just getting mated or yeah  there's a massive massive threat as  you're correctly pointing out and uh  yeah your other options are just sort of  the same with words yeah you can you can  try playing Queen F6 but then most  likely even the Queens don't come off  like you will just get unless you you  know here we maybe get  conversation  yeah so 36 might still be giving you the  same end game  queen of six white but this is worse  because the root yet doesn't get to A3  uh even okay even better this is  actually lost probably yeah this looks  and it's very close for sure  yeah this this looks straight up lost to  me  okay Queen E3 he's gotta do it